[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
de la transition énergétique chers
collègues la crise actuelle a mis en
évidence la dépendance énergétique de la
France tant financière que quantitative
et il me semble indispensable de
consolider à la fois nos filières de
production énergétique et de
développement durable sans y sacrifier
notre indépendance aujourd'hui la
Moselle nous en fournit les moyens et je
vous ai écrit à ce sujet il y a déjà
plusieurs mois trois forages de
recherche ont permis d'identifier un
immense volume de gaz certifié de P le
gisement du gaz lorrain représente au
total un volume de 190 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz soit environ 5
années de consommation de gaz pour la
France d'un point de vue technique son
exploitation présente l'avantage décisif
de ne pas recourir aux techniques de
fracturation hydraulique ou d'autres
procédés polluants à la différence
notable du gaz de schiste de sorte que
l'utilisation de ce gisement réduirait
de 10 fois l'empreinte carbone de la
fourniture de gaz actuel
aujourd'hui une entreprise française se
tient prête à assurer l'exploitation de
ce gaz à investir près de 20 millions
d'euros et à créer de nouveaux emplois
pour se faire il serait même possible
après extraction du gaz de réaliser des
enfouissement de CO2 dans le sous-sol
ainsi libéré le temps de l'action est
donc venu il est suspendu à l'accord du
gouvernement concernant l'attribution
d'une concession d'exploitation à
l'entreprise qui se fait attendre depuis
maintenant trois ans cet accord
renforcerait notre souveraineté
énergétique au regard de nos relations
extérieures avec d'autres pays et d'un
contexte global imprévisible il
contribuerait à stabiliser notre
situation économique marquée par une
hausse du prix du gaz et du coup
supporté par les entreprises et les
ménages il traduirait enfin notre
engagement sur le plan écologique et en
venir en mental si vous partagez ces
objectifs madame la ministre
l'exploitation du gaz lorrain peut-elle
compter sur votre soutien